are you guys hoping we're doing pretty
good I'm out in the woods with my wife
and our dogs and I'm actually in our
treehouse right now and a little my
little studio lair but I think we're all
doing good we're staying positive and
trying to stay busy and Tyler and I did
a zoom songwriting session today so that
was provided that's pretty cool we did
one last week and so you know trying to
try to have some normalcy and continue
to do what we do it's obviously in a
different different form but you got to
adapt and you know we love what we do so
we're trying to continue to do it you
know no matter what but thinking about
everybody on the front lines and saying
our prayers every night that we can get
through this you know as soon as we as
soon as possible and praying for just
the health and safety of the world and
you know it's just some interesting
times but you know we believe God will
get us through this and just gotta stay
positive
amen to that and self-isolation it has
that really giving you more to creating
more music has it inspired you has it
made you want to talk in a different way
when you create music I think so a
little bit you know even even this
morning alright we were just hungry to
write something that had some meaning
and some meat to it something that could
impact the world
you know music we say the music is
medicine music is eeling and no for us
as creatives and as artists you know
even just playing guitar and write music
and being able to kind of put your heart
out that way it really is therapeutic
you know and it really is something that
fortunately a virus can't take it away
from us and we're just really thankful
to have that and you know in this time
we spent a lot of time just trying to
better our craft and a lot of times
creativity gets taken away when you get
too busy so I think he's really been
healthy and cool to be home with not too
many to-do list and just being able to
just allow creativity to happen so it's
been a it's been a good time yeah music
really does bring you joy and also when
crying babies are in your background of
your Instagram post Tyler what was
happening at that moment
no we don't we captured that moment we
have incredible babies that don't cry
son and when they do it's like the other
one sees one crying and they both have
to cry and at that moment we have been
working on the ACN thing at BK's house
and it was a long night for them it was
about their bedtime and they just both
broke down and we catched that moment
had had to hold on to that video we
thought that was definitely a picture of
real life and time for us so we uh we
had to capture it and you have another
baby coming along a baby boy
congratulations thank you thank you or
uh we're excited and looking forward to
it and our hands are gonna be full and
we're excited to be done after this
anyway no we're good Hayley's doing well
she's uh she's a trouper I feel like
she's only known pregnancy for the last
three years so she's ready to not be
pregnant but she really is a trouper
she's working out through it and just
staying really positive even when she
feels like she needs to go throw up or
something and it's just it's inspiring
she's incredible so for all women who
you know go through the pregnancy
process I have so much respect for for
sure and you gave birth to a beautiful
song I love my country how refreshing is
to have that song right now don't you
love it you know we do we're so thankful
to have that song out and you know some
of our good buddies wrote that back in
2018 so we've been jamming it for a
while the demo didn't sound anything
like that but uh you know it got pitched
around town and kind of ended back up
where it started was was you know in our
in our hands in terms of us just jamming
it loving it and loving it
and so you know off this next record we
just felt like this needed to be first
it was time and especially with
everything going on and our fans have
been asking for new music it just felt
like the right move and we don't want to
overthink it we wanted to put something
out that allowed our fans and anybody to
just kind of get out of the moment of
what the world is going on with this
world and things are confusing times are
weird but you know here's a song to make
you dance and get outside your head and
enjoy your family enjoy those around you
that you're coordinating with
and so yeah thanks we're just loving the
feedback and you know just super
thankful to have music out and you know
we are really pulling for everything to
turn around and you know we missed we
missed being on the road we missed
connecting with our fans and you know
again we can't just we can't thank the
people on the front lines the doctors
nurses people delivering food there's so
many people to thank but uh you know our
our hearts and prayers and thoughts are
with those daily and you know we'll
continue to do that too we still we all
seem to stir together yeah it's a
refreshing song and your fifth album is
out and will be coming out soon actually
and you're not scared of changing up
your sound you guys are you like going
for you like trying new things so how
would you describe this album to your
fans if we had to describe it
I think it would be we would probably
used the word nostalgic I think we've
really been attracted and drawn to songs
whether we're writing songs or listening
to our songs that take us back to kind
of the beginning of FGL and you know the
2012 here's are the good times out of
them so we're we're sort of channeling
you know old Florida Georgia line but
elevating it and evolving it into 2020
and still who we are today as far as
content and all that goes but just
having fun with it we've we've had more
fun making this album through the
process and I think any other album and
it's just got you know kind of given us
new life new energy and these songs are
so fun and we can't we're really excited
for the world to hear them so can't wait
to get them out and with this this means
you've changed your release date and
it's changing your tour date it's
changing everything because everything
everything that's happening right now
for everybody do you have future plans
for it in terms of your tour I think
right now you know it's funny I feel
like we're literally on God's time yeah
and it's hard to stay I mean we're just
trying to be contained take it
day-by-day and stay creative and make
music it's really hard to say when it's
winter you can really kick back up again
I think it's gonna be a lot longer than
we anticipate but right now we're just
trusting God and
somebody said that the other diagonal
wow it's really true the whole world is
on god's time right now and he is the
one that's in control of this whole
thing so it's uh you know we're just
trying to lean on that and know that and
still stay connected with our things as
much as possible and use this time to
work on our craft and our smell writing
and try to elevate where we can you know